pour étendre pu éviter les scènes de
violence les scènes de pillage commises
par les casseurs ce samedi lors du 18e
acte de mobilisation des gilet jaune
y at-il eu des défaillances et un manque
d'anticipation
faut-il appeler cela de l'amateurisme
toutes ces questions les français se les
posent ils ne veulent plus débattre ils
ne veulent plus de discours plus de
formules médiatique
ils veulent des actes nous ne sommes
plus dans le cadre de maintiennent de
l'ordre classique à la suite des
événements du 1er octobre à l'arc de
triomphe nous attendions déjà de votre
part des actes forts
or vous n'avez rien fait de plus et ne
rien faire de plus c'est laisser faire
aujourd'hui aucune mesure politique ne
pourra apaiser durablement la situation
ce n'est pas vos incantations qui
calmeront le pays encore au moins le
recours à l'armée monsieur le ministre
votre en même temps dans le domaine
régalien est un véritable échec
il faut adopter la scène politique qui
vaille celle de la fermeté à la hauteur
de la violence celle que le sénat vous
propose depuis le mois de juin
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
me dire à combien se chiffrent les
dégâts qui va les payer
les français qui verront leurs
cotisations d'assurance augmentent et où
êtes vous un fameux prêt de faire payer
les casseurs
et puis je vous rappelle ma question
s'adresser au premier ministre etes-vous
sûr
êtes vous sûr êtes vous sûr qu'avec un
tel discrédit
le ministre de l'intérieur est encore à
mesure de poursuivre sa mission place
beauvau merci la parole et au secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le rhône une aise avec la
parole monsieur lui d'y aller dit
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice christine bonfanti je suis de
remarques par rapport à votre question
d'abord je suis très heureux de
constater que maintenant vous nous
expliquer que ce à quoi nous avons à
faire face depuis le 17 novembre
ça n'est pas du maintien de l'ordre
classique ça n'est pas toujours ce qui a
été dit sur ces bancs je vous le
rappelle depuis le début nous disons de
ce mouvement il étant empreint d'une
très grande violence d'une remise en
cause de nos institutions nous avons
souvent parlé sédition je suis heureux
que depuis quelques semaines seulement
vous nous rejoignez sur cette thématique
quelques semaines seulement mais nous
n'avons pas attendu que vous évoluez
dans l'analyse des faits et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que nous sommes ici
et que nous gérons nous ce problème
c'est ce que les français souhaitaient
tous soyons là en gestion d après le
premier descendant d après le 1er
décembre
nous avons fait évoluer la doctrine nous
avons fait évoluer cette doctrine nous
n'avons pas rien fait les organisations
syndicales que nous voyons régulièrement
avec christophe castaner nous ont
remerciés de cette évolution de doctrine
ils nous ont remerciés de cette latitude
qui leur a été laissé dans
l'interpellation dans la possibilité
d'agir
dix mille personnes interpellées 1800
personnes placées qui ont été jugés 40%
de peines de prison ferme comment osez
vous dire que nous ne faisons rien
comment osez vous dire que nous ne
faisons rien et nous allons continuer et
nous serons présents ce samedi à nouveau
samedi dernier nos instructions n'ont
pas été appliquées et c'est très grave
c'est un dysfonctionnement majeur et ce
sont les policiers eux mêmes qui se sont
adressés à nous pour se plaindre de ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas reçu les bonne
instruction
alors samedi nous continuerons à assurer
l'ordre républicain nous considérons
nous continuerons à protéger la
république parce que c'est ce que nous
faisons et je vous demande simplement
vous interrogez vous que feriez vous à
notre place que s'est il passé entre
2007 et 2012
que s'est il passé entre deux villes
en 2017 il y a eu beaucoup d'incidents
d'ordre public
il y a eu beaucoup d'incidents d'ordre
public et nous nous avons pris des
mesures à la fois législatives et des
mesures opérationnelles qui vise à y
mettre un terme
et dès demain d2d samedi tous les
attroupements qui se réuniront qui
comporteront des casseurs seront comme
nous l'avons annoncé immédiatement
dispersés merci